[Musique]
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle thinker view on aurait aimé un
petit peu à voir votre
vision sur les marchés financiers sur la
politique de certains états en termes de
questions monétaires d'évasion fiscale
et des petites joyeusetés nous avons
aujourd'hui philippe béchade et jérôme
cazes philippe béchade présentez vous je
vous écoute je suis à l'origine un
trader sur les marchés dérivés et puis
j'ai bifurqué au début des années 90
vers l'information financière j'ai créé
cercle finance
depuis 2000 je collabore avec les
éditions agora et je suis actuellement
rédacteur en chef à la bourse au
quotidien je m'occupe plus long de tous
les contenus traitant de la
macroéconomie et puis accessoirement je
suis président des iconoclastes je re 15
je ne suis pas du tout un financier j'ai
longtemps et est un assureur j'ai dirigé
le groupe coface et à ce titre j'ai
participé au comité de direction
générale d'une grande banque qui
commence par na qui finit park 6 et j'ai
été tellement fff a réparé la finance de
marché que j'ai décidé de consacrer une
partie de mon énergie à dénoncer cette
espèce de malheur qui nous est arrivé
depuis une vingtaine d'années j'ai écrit
un thriller qu on peut trouver
gratuitement sur internet qui s'appelle
5 5,5 jeudi rouge
et j'essaie de d'alerté sur les
défaillances graves et les continue de
la réglementation financière
accessoirement j'ai fait une start up
pour faciliter les communications entre
les petites entreprises et tous leurs
partenaires qui s'appelle my cercle on
va rester sur vous jérôme cazes vous
essayé d'alerter sur le système
financier
quels sont les dangers qui peuvent se
matérialiser devant nous
à court moyen et long terme
à mon sens les dangers sont les mêmes
qui a huit ans c'est à dire que on a une
finance de marché qui s'est développé de
manière absolument invraisemblable en
volume en importance dans l'ensemble des
mécanismes économiques
elle était très importante il ya huit
ans elle est tout aussi importante
aujourd'hui pas plus importante si on
prend un certain nombre de paramètres de
volume elle est plus importante
aujourd'hui est plus important encore
que le volume 1 des problèmes à mon sens
que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est celui
de la taille des plus gros animaux qu'on
perd à raison que je fais toujours ses
dires les petits animaux font des
petites bêtises les gros animaux font
des grosses bêtises est donc une des
manières dans un univers où on sait pas
grand chose et où oui on peut pas
toujours invoqué le principe de
précaution donc de temps en temps il
faut prendre des risques une des
manières d'éviter les risques atroce
c'est d'avoir des entités des
organisations qu'ils soient pas trop
grande pour qu'elles fassent pas de trop
grosses bêtises et donc on avait de trop
grosses banques en 2008 et les grosses
banques sont devenues encore plus grosse
aujourd'hui et on est toujours dans un
syndrome des gens qui sont censés
contrôler les banques qui pour leur
confort intellectuel plus que pour la
paix de la planète sont toujours dans
l'idée que les gros c'est quand même
sympathique parce que ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on fait avec eux ils savent nous
prendre dans le sens du poil nous
régulateurs et donc on aime bien les
petits c'est compliqué ça peut se casser
la figure et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à se dire que dans une économie
il est normal qu'ils aient des choses
qui se casse la figure et des petites
choses qui se casse la figure ça fait
pas les titres des journaux et ça fait
de mal à personne des grosses choses qui
se casse la figure ça fait ce qu'on a vu
en 2008
philippe béchade quelles sont les
grosses choses qui vont se casser qui
vont se casser la figure selon vous à
court moyen et long terme
je ne peux pas ce que je n'ai pas de
boule de cristal
annoncé
et voudrait si le scénario
je peux vous parler des potentialités de
big problème
on parlait des gros animaux font de
grosses bêtises je pense que celui qui
aujourd'hui
nous met dans la situation la plus
explosive c'est la chine la chine en
2000 ces 1500 milliards de pib
aujourd'hui ses dix mille 300 milliards
de pib
la chine
en 2005 2006
c'était trois mille milliards de dette
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus de 33
milliards ces dernières données dont on
dispose donc on voit que la dette
chinoise celle de l'état des régions des
entreprises qui sont des conglomérats le
plus souvent
étatique la globalité de cette dette qui
est directement gérée par le
gouvernement chinois aujourd'hui donc
c'est dix fois la taille du pib chinois
la chine aujourd'hui représente
à peu près 15 % du commerce mondial
mais sur les deux cent mille milliards
de dettes aujourd'hui la chine en
représente également plus de plus de 15%
les etats-unis revendique ou à vous
dix huit mille milliards de dette sansan
3% du pib
la chine ces trois cent pour cent du pib
ce qui est à peu près comparable au
japon on se souvient qu'au japon de
redonner 90 on avait également connu une
explosion de la dette des mauvaises
dettes du surinvestissement partout de
la bulle immobilière on a absolument
tous ces ingrédients en chine mais à une
échelle qui est qui et quatre ou cinq
fois celle que le japon représentait en
1990 jérôme
on fait comment pour réguler tout ça
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord le en
gros quand est ce qu'il ya une crise une
crise il faut que ce soit gros on l'a
dit il faut qu'ils les anticipations
positives on commence à voir aujourd'hui
des bruits négatif sur la chine enfin
malgré tout les débats c'est pour dire
est ce qu'ils vont faire visiter ce
qu'ils vont c'est vers cette vous n'y
connaissez rien ils vont faire six et
demi enfin ça reste des anticipations
extrêmement positive personne n'a
vraiment de scénario assez vu des
anticipations avec des lunettes roses ou
c'est les anticipations aux sources et
fondis mais peu de monde sait exactement
quand france se fabriquent les
statistiques chinoises et à vrai dire
aujourd'hui la chine reste un fantasme
et avant c'était aussi un fantasme
simplement ça n'avait pas vraiment
d'importance pour l'économie mondiale
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie importance
pour l'économie mondiale donc ils sont
gros les anticipations restent
globalement positives et leur expertise
leur chien assureurs donc je pense que
en gros le futur ressemble quand même un
tout petit peu au passé c'est pas des
gens très malins les assureurs me
regarde le passé donc en gros une
organisation elle est d'autant plus
aguerris qu'elle al'habitude de résoudre
des problèmes on peut pas dire que le
management chinois soit très habitué à
régler des problèmes de crise financière
grave ou alors ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que toutes leurs traditions c'est de le
régler de manière brutale et donc c'est
vrai que j'ai pas du tout maintenant
plus de boule de cristal donc ça peut
tout à fait surgir un autre endroit mais
on voit bien que en chine il ya les
principaux ingrédients pour qu'ils y ait
des choses qui surprennent de manière
négative et que du coup tout le monde se
replie sur soi et qu'on aime une crise
comme on en a tous les tous les huit ou
dix ans l'europe le scénario comme pour
l'europe
l'europe moi j'ai toujours été positif
sur l'europe c'est à dire que j'observe
que on n'arrête pas de se faire des
petites peurs sur l'europe mais ça reste
des petites peurs
en gros pour qui y est écrit il faut
quand même qu'ils aient déjà eu
les anticipations et de la croissance
dans un univers 1% de croissance
avec des anticipations qui sont aussi 1%
il est très difficile de bâtir un
scénario de catastrophe donc pour moi
l'europe à de graves problèmes de
gouvernance de graves problèmes liés aux
flux démographiques oui il ya des
preuves mais c'est pas ça qui va mettre
là toute la planète en crise à mon sens
philippe béchade l'europe ces pleureuses
l'instant va bien commence juste à se
demander si nos banques sont pas un
petit peu exposées elles aussi sur le
high yield
et sur des dettes fragiles liées à
l'industrie du pétrole donc les
dernières estimations qu'on a c'est 180
milliards aux états unis alors là les la
fourchette elle est très très vaste et
là qui disent qu'ils à 560 milliards de
dettes liées aux juniors aux nouveaux
acteurs du shale oil
certains prétendent que on serait plutôt
bien au delà
d'emile des 1000 milliards
bon si c'est vraiment 1000 milliards on
est à peu près sur l'ordre de grandeur
des subprimes en 2007 et à l'époque le
taux de défaillance des sondes price a
commencé vraiment imposé problème et a
créé vraiment ddd des faillites en
cascade lorsque le taux de défaut a
dépassé les 7
en europe on n'est certainement pas à
une hypothèse de 7% de taux de défaut
sur
toute la dette liée à l'industrie
pétrolière
là par contre où je reste très soucieux
et pour revenir un petit peu sur
l'endettement chinois c'est que une
dette qui croît de façon exponentielle
mais avec des perspectives de croissance
mettons à l'horizon 2020 est-ce qu'on
pouvait encore espérer un doublement du
pib de la chine si l'endettement reste
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui 33 mille
milliards et qu'on a une poursuite de la
croissance on peut dire que la dette à
terme pourrait être résorbé
par les fruits produits par l'économie
par la capacité des entreprises à faire
face à leurs à leurs engagements mais
aujourd'hui
les gens que je discute un petit peu de
la chine ne disent probablement on n'est
pas très au delà des 4 % de croissance
en chine et on a une dette qui elle par
contre continue de croître de façon
exponentielle
on est à 33 mille milliards aujourd'hui
se pourrait qu'on franchissent
allègrement la barre des 36 milliards
d'ici la fin de l'année le japon 90
présentait des bulles dans tous les
domaines du surinvestissement
surcapacités mais c'était quand même une
économie non régulé et une économie qui
s'inscrivait
dans le commerce mondial au sens où
l'entendent ceux qui parlent d'un marché
libre en chine tout est administré
les 33 milliards de dettes dont je vous
parle ce sont celles qui sont connues
mais il ya le shadow banking
les dark pools alors ça les dark pools
c'est tout à fait autre chose
le shadow banking c'est quoi ces
des façons de contourner géré par les
restrictions que qu'impose la banque
centrale de chine c'est tout le
contraire n'impose aucune restriction à
la balance de l'argent à tout va mais ça
ne suffit pas encore temps iliad
entreprises qui sont en difficulté dans
le champ d'onal au shadow banking c'est
une façon de rajouter encore du crédit
de l'argent dans le système jérôme
shadow banking dark pools régulation
financière les pouvoirs publics tant
européen qu'américain que chinois
visant son goût là au niveau de la
régulation qu'est ce que mais il faut
qu'il ya une grande schizophrénie
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est à dire
qu'à la fois on dit qu'on est un peu
inquiet par certains éléments shadow
banking et autres mais en même temps
chaque fois qu'on a un problème on
essaie de se sauver par la dette
c'est à dire que on a affirmé en 2008
que
on avait trop de dettes et qu'on allait
remettre les choses à plat aujourd'hui
on a encore plus de dette qu'en 2008 et
n'ont pas fait alors parce que personne
n'a envie d'une ce que cette manière si
on remonte un cran plus loin c'est que
on est gorgé a deux espoirs un espoir de
cons croissance comme les gens se
parlent plus
arif eu à se mettre d'accord il ya une
panique de se dire bon sens si demain il
n'y a pas un gros gâteau ce partage et
on va se mettre sur la gueule et donc
nos sociétés sont devenus des sociétés
qui savent plus fonctionner de sa flux
bâtir de désaccord si la fin s'il ya pas
de croissance et d'un autre côté en plus
on est en plus vous avez les stocks de
dettes et d'actifs plus vous avez des
stocks d'epargne et de gens qui
attendent des revenus et donc on a un
bout de nous-mêmes qui dit bah oui c'est
quand même bien tout ça il faut qu'il
faut qu'ils aient du rendement est donc
aujourd'hui on est incapable de se
passer de la dette et donc on n'a pas
réussi aujourd'hui elle en a parlé de la
chine mais il ya les autres pays en
développement à la fin des fins est
presque anecdotique à part pour
l'investisseur de savoir où est-ce que
ça va casser ce qu'on sait c'est que
quand il ya trop de dettes qui
s'accumulent à un moment donné ça casse
et quand ça casse ça se matérialise
comment il ya un actif qui perd de sa
valeur brutalement et puis les gens qui
étaient dessus sont que leurs yeux pour
pleurer
philippe quand on n'a plus que ses yeux
pour pleurer
qui a beaucoup de milliards derrière et
que ça commence à faire pleurer les
états
les chaînes locales on a un scénario
noir je pense qu'il faut investir dans
l'industrie du mouchoir parce que la
valeur beaucoup d'yeux effectivement à
éponger
le problème de la dette
n'est pas n'est pas effrayant dans un
monde en croissance
nous avons un monde où le rythme de la
croissance est en train est en train de
ces de train de chuter
la dette génère
génère des intérêts et pour limiter la
charge que ça représente on est en train
de basculer partout dans les taux
négatifs la banque centrale suisse a été
la première à expérimenter ça au début
des années 80 et puis elle s'y est remis
récemment après avoir abandonné
brutalement le lien entre l'euro et le
franc suisse la banque centrale suédoise
est déjà bien avancé puis nous avons
ensuite la banque du danemark nous avons
la banque centrale européen qui s'y est
mise on a au moins six des treize
membres de la fed qui se sont exprimées
depuis l'été dernier en faveur d'une
réflexion concernant le recours aux taux
négatifs et là dessus vous avez la fed
qui en décembre décide de relever le
loyer de l'argent alors pas de beaucoup
c'est assez symbolique beaucoup disent
aujourd'hui que c'était le pire moment
pour le faire mais la fed n'a pris
qu'une seule initiative
l'année dernière la bce une initiative
qui était effectivement de lancer le cul
et
d'adopter les taux de prise en pension
négatif elle va peut-être les rendent
encore plus négatifs et la banque
centrale du japon qui a beaucoup promis
vient juste à l'instant
de passer également au taux négatifs
pendant que les trois principales
grandes banques us
eurozone japon prenait une initiative la
banque centrale chinoise combien at elle
pris d'initiative monétaire en 2015 bah
ça rime
75,75 initiative monétaire alors
d'assouplissement des règles
prudentielles
des injections alors tantôt en faveur
des régions tantôt en faveur d'un
secteur industriel des baisses de taux
et elle dit qu'elle a encore de la marge
ce qui est vrai puisque je crois que les
taux chinois sont encore au delà de 4
donc il ya encore comme on dit de
l'espace pour baisser les taux mais
quand une banque centrale prend 75
initiatives au cours de la même année
est ce qu'on n'a pas l'impression que là
on est un petit peu dans la frénésie bon
et que signifie tu es là je vais vous
dresser le tableau
ont commencé à voir des gars un peu
partout donc comme on sort des flux de
migrants peu partout de jantes en flux
de niort économique le milan dû à la
guerre on assiste à une balkanisation
d'un politique européenne
si les marchés financiers viennent un
petit peu nous mettre du sel sur les
plaies
c'est à dire que si on voit le kilo de
riz prendre un peu d'inflation dû à
beaucoup d'injections de liquidités par
des banques centrales américaine
votre avis la france est elle est
positionnée comme ans pour pouvoir dire
les copains faut peut-être ralentir un
peu avec les chiens john je te
positionner de quel point de vue on a
essayé d'appeler une réglementation
système économique mondial d'une façon
plus raisonnée est ce que on a encore la
voix de la france est écouté mais de
toute façon la france dans ce domaine là
et
du côté de la non réglementation
la france est dans une logique qui date
de colbert qui est de dire
les grandes banques françaises c'est la
france est en fait l'intérêt national
s'identifient à l'intérêt de mes grands
champions nationaux et 7 cette idée là
va du parti communiste jusqu'au front
national il ya une espèce d'unanimité
nationale sur ce sujet donc aujourd'hui
la france a toujours freiné des quatre
fers sur tout ce qui pouvait être
réglementation financière donc je ne
pense pas que ça change rapidement on a
vu la volte face quand même de notre
président de la république
la firme annonce finalement c'est ça
qu'est ce qu'il avait dit la finance et
les novices et la finance et après il a
fait une loi sous pression des lobbys
bnp paribas et autres pour éviter
préempter une réglementation européenne
qui auraient déjà été assez tiédasse
mais qui grâce à ça a été scié à la
cheville et qui a conduit à faire que le
temps s'est éloigné et qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus beaucoup de pression alors il
faut pas complètement injurier l'avenir
ses dires il peut y avoir il ya encore
des initiatives à bruxelles mais par
rapport à la france la france na n'est
pas acteur sur ce dossier la france et
freins sur ce dossier qui est ce qu'il
faut les voir dans le monde qui est
actif sur la réglementation financière
mais le aujourd'hui le parlement
européen discute de mesures qui
reviennent sur l'un des trois problèmes
qu'on a à mon avis aujourd'hui on a
trois problèmes le premier on en a déjà
parlé c'est les animaux trop gros c'est
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à dire à un
moment donné que plus c'est gros plus
alors on commence à le faire un petit
peu en disant plus puisque ces grosses
cuisses que ça paye du capital le
deuxième problème c'est de sanctionner
les dirigeants parce qu'à un moment une
organisation dans une école une marche
et elle elle fonctionne quand même sur
le principe du chef et si le chef n'a
jamais de sanctions
l'organisation et jouit dans fait d'une
d'une impunité et puis le troisième
élément c'est la séparation des
activités de marché d autres activités
pas pour dire qu'elles sont sales
qu'elles sont anti national je sais pas
quoi mais pour dire que ce sont des
activités qui devaient être cantonnés
pour ne pas justement le jour où elle
dérape et c'est normal quand on fait des
parts et que de temps en temps ce bourg
qu'elles ne viennent pas polluer
l'ensemble du système dont on a besoin
c'est à dire une monnaie dans laquelle
tout le monde a confiance un crédit dans
lequel on a tout le monde a confiance et
d'arriver à séparer cette finance qui
est un service public finalement de
l'autre finances qui est une activité
qui en effet sa part être ça va
s'apparenter à des paris quelquefois
marche quelquefois marche pas les
sanctions vous préconisez quoi ça les
sanctions c'est en gros c'est les
amender la prison va pas on va pas
réveiller le la rule la pendaison donc
les pendules et les les sanctions elles
sont connues depuis la nuit des temps le
problème c'est que vont elles sont un
seul clic parce que l'aller les lois
sont pas faites pour toucher les
dirigeants en gros on va on va toucher
au porte-monnaie beaucoup si on est aux
états unis symboliquement si on est en
france l'entreprise mais l'entreprise on
le voit bien chaque fois qu'une banque
ait sanctionné lendemain on a même dans
leur même on a un communiqué où il ya
même pas mal
parce qu'elle doit rassurer ses
actionnaires est libre vous m'avez fil
des 3 milliards d'hommes c'est pas grave
je vais quand même sortir un bon
résultat trimestriel donc sanctionné
l'entreprise n'a aucune importance en
revanche on est tous des êtres humains
et si on veut faire passer un message il
faut dire il ya une énorme bêtise fait
dans cette entreprise il ya eu donc un
défaut de surveillance la surveillance
c'est quand même le dirigeant mais le
dirigeant où il va être interdit de
travailler dans la banque pendant dix
ans où il va être à aller en prison et
le jour où on aura un ou deux dirigeants
de banques en prison j'ai un peu
travaillé en entreprise je sais comment
ça marche
garantie que brusquement va verrouiller
un certain nombre de choses dans les
banques puis les sanctions les dirigeons
pas poursuivi est ce que c'est du fait
aussi que les banques détiennent des
dettes de partis politiques que si les
banques n'étaient pas derrière les
partis politiques les partis politiques
ne pourrait pas financer
je croyais déjà sur le principe too big
to fail too big to jail c'est à dire que
donc l'électrolysé des établissements
hyper systémique
il n'y a aucune sanction qui peut
s'appliquer contre eux d'abord parce
qu'elles sont
étroitement superviser d'ailleurs la
banque centrale européenne s'en vante le
comité de supervision qui a rendu son
rapport début janvier à bien
on va dire verrouillé évalué pesé
soupesé le risque et n'a rien détecté
d'alarmant bon le fait que la deutsche
bank par exemple et 52 mille milliards
d'encours sur les dérivés c'est à dire
trois fois et demi le pib de l'allemagne
ça n'a pas l'air de véritablement
effrayer grand monde en europe il ya au
moins quatre banques dont l'encours sur
les dérivés est supérieur à 30 mille
milliards de dollars et aux états unis
on est peu à peu près sur les mêmes
dimensions que vous preniez les jeep est
mort quand morgan stanley
citigroup donc tous ces gens là tout
j'aime trop gros pour aller en prison
mais ils sont aujourd'hui si jamais on
leur reprocher quelque chose ils
diraient 'nous sommes superviser
aujourd'hui on est à l'écouté on
travaille sous le contrôle de la banque
centrale ou sous le contrôle de la sec
et avait passé la course en temps quand
je vous entends parler tout le jeu bon
je vous connais on l'a on va pas se
mentir on se connaît bien
quand je vous entends j'ai l'impression
de
pouvoir des gouvernements qui
fonctionnent avec des cannes ou avec des
aides d'assistance comme dans les
voitures
la voiture a été mal conçu reprend je
sais pas rappelez vous une voiture de
chez un constructeur français qui avait
besoin de toutes ces aides électroniques
pour pouvoir prendre un virage à 35
kilomètres heure
on voit on voit ces gouvernements avec
des cannes et si on commence à enlever
une canne c'est le système n'est plus
très stable et que les propriétaires des
cannes c'est à dire les banques
font clairement passer le message que
faites attention
vous enlever nos cannes on va vous
emmener tous au fond donc je reprends
l'expression publique et c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai à partir du moment où en gros
on met ensemble dans le même bateau
les activités de marché et les activités
financières de base que le commun des
mortels appel banques c'est-à-dire la
monnaie et le crédit ils ont raison
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné s'ils
s'y mettent les crosse en l'air comme
enfermé au 19e et bah tout s'arrête et
c'est cette espèce de chantage de base
qui fait qu'à un moment donné aucun
gouvernement ne peut en effet dire vais
y aller crever allez je vous prends au
mot je vous laisse crever là au bord de
la route c'est pas possible parce que
c'est lui nous font croire que vous
emmène tous savaient qu est ce qu on a
tous nos comptes dans ces banques là et
on ne peut pas se permettre ça comment
on fait quand on est braquée par
quelqu'un qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
messieurs ce qui nous braquer c'est un
braquage c'est le casse du siècle oui
nous brac d'une certaine manière tout le
monde est complice à les gouvernements
sont complices d'une certaine tout ça
c'est organisé en 25 ans
sous les yeux de chacun enfin c'est pas
un secret c'est pas une mafia au sens ce
traditionnel bon un système s'est bâtie
comme ça il est le premier lobby en
termes financiers dans n'importe quelle
économie développée en france en europe
et aux états unis il a donc des leviers
absolument invraisemblable tu connais le
volume de l'argent investi en lobbying
bancaire non je le connais pas je ne le
connais pas je sais que le fbi d'avoir
un budget de 50 millions d'euros mais
on peut aussi regarder le nombre
d'énarques je lis à chez bnp paribas
enfin le problème il n'est pas
uniquement cet argent là parce que les
gens vraiment très haut dans un pays
comme la france c'est pas avec de
l'argent qu'on l'achète on l'achève avec
des mouvements de personnes et des
services rendus et en gros c'est un
système particulièrement en france où on
est très efficace pour rendre des
services embaucher des gens et faire
tourner les gens dans une dans un petit
monde donc à un moment donné en effet il
n'ya que les citoyens qui pourront dire
arrêtons ce système là on a raté la
fenêtre de 2008 je suis d'un naturel
optimiste mais j'ai peur qu'il faille
une nouvelle crise pour qu'on ait une
nouvelle fenêtre et j'espère qu'on
prendra les choses de manière un peu
plus rigoureuse philippe ce que tu y
crois
je pense que dans le domaine de la
finance
on ne prend des décisions que lorsqu'on
est arrivé dans le platane et en 2008
c'est même pas sûr qu'on ait pris les
bonnes décisions puisqu'on a remis le
même chauffeur c'est par une voiture
dont on a encore gonflé le turbo et moi
une question que je me pose il j'ai
commencé dans la finance en 85 à
l'époque où edith cresson disait la
bourse je la ferme les boursiers je les
enferme mais à l'époque on se
préoccupait beaucoup du politique on se
préoccupait beaucoup du géopolitique on
se préoccupait de lénine et de
l'innovation on se préoccupait de huy de
beaucoup de choses qui intéressent à
l'époque les historiens et depuis 87 88
petit à petit le seul sujet de
conversation sur les marchés c'est
qu'est ce que va faire la banque
centrale la banque centrale jusque dans
les allées jusqu'à vainement de monsieur
greenspan était un petit peu larbitre
sur le terrain donc elle était là pour
laisser se dérouler le beau jeu si j'ose
dire et puis la banque centrale on l'a
vu prendre de plus en plus de sifflet
siffler penalty s'il fait des coups
francs et puis petit à petit le jeu est
de plus en plus haché est de plus en
plus on se demande mais qu'est décision
verdonck va donc prendre larbitre et
puis un moment l' arbitre siffle penalty
sur penalty et ckoi anti tati visible
sur quantitative easing injection de la
terre sur injection monétaire mais si on
dit qu'il n'ya plus de match ce n'est
plus qu'une séance de tirs au but c'est
à dire qu'on investit plus on ne se pose
plus la question de savoir ce qui se
passe vraiment dans l'économie dans le
monde est ce que notre planète peut
supporter que la chine par exemple comme
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure voit son
pib doubler encore d'ici 2000 allez
mettons 2025 soyons raisonnables on se
pose plus ce genre de question la
question c'est qu'est ce que va nous
déclarer par exemple la fed lors de sa
prochaine réunion en mars est-ce qu'elle
va reconnaître qu'il s'est trompé en
montant les taux en décembre
est-ce que
la bce va rendre les taux encore plus
négatif en fait on a complètement oublié
le contexte on en est simplement à
savoir combien est-ce que l'arbitré
sifflera de penalty en 2016 et donc on
n'a plus besoin de joueurs voilà plus
besoin que de gens qui tirent des
penaltys et le gardien but à la limite
peu s'accouder au poteau et regardez
regardez les balles on rentrait on en
est un petit peu là c'est à dire que on
a les banques centrales qui mène le jeu
et ses banques centrales ne sont évalués
par personne si elle se trompe ou celles
fondées eu des erreurs que je pourrai
qualifiée de colossal là ils sont
totalement indépendants non à répondre
devant aucun comité d'experts il n'y a
rien au dessus de la banque gérait
comment on fait pour que les gens se
réapproprient
c'est à dire prendre conscience que la
banque centrale augmente c'est tout le
monde s'en fout mais tout le monde s'en
fout sauf ceux qui travaillent dans la
finance en attendant on ne s'en fout pas
il ya un espèce de consensus en gros il
ya une règle économique qui fait que
quand les taux baissent les actifs
montrent la bourse monte donc en gros
comme il ya plutôt des gens qui ont
intérêt à ce qu bourse monte et un
espèce de consensus mots pour dire c'est
quand même sympa quand les taux baissent
donc c'est un problème de caste non à 96
et je crois qu'il ya un problème de
fonctionnement de l'économie qui est qui
est devenu relativement pervers après
parce qu'il ya quand même plusieurs
problèmes dans tout ce qu'on discute ici
je pense qu'il ya un problème de castes
dans un certain nombre de décisions de
régulation qu'on n'arrive pas à prendre
après il ya un fonctionnement du système
qui est devenu complètement pervers qui
fait que les banques centrales c'est
vrai que c'est le pouvoir ultime mais si
on se met à leur place on voit que
finalement leur degré de liberté est
pratiquement nul donc on est dans un
monde où ceux qui incarnent le pouvoir
absolu ont finalement un bras de levier
absolument nul pourquoi parce que ça
fait huit ans qu'ils baissent les taux
qu'ils mettent de plus en plus de
liquidités et que quand il y en a un qui
dit tiens allez je vais faire autre
chose
la banque centrale américaine
la fin de l'année dernière elle le fait
après avoir hésité pendant des années et
immédiatement après tout le monde se dit
peut-être qu'elle a fait une grosse une
grosse bêtise donc pour moi ça donne pas
l'impression de quelqu'un de puissant
quand finalement le degré de liberté
c'est de faire comme les autres
c'est-à-dire de dire je baisse les taux
quand ils sont à zéro je remets de la
liquidité parce que je peux plus baisser
les taux plus bas alors on en gros il ya
plus de pilote dans l'avion c'est quand
même ça la réalité il ya plus de pilote
dans l'avion parce qu'à partir du moment
où on a laissé les marchés prendre le
pouvoir la logique du marché c'est quand
même de dire c'est gentil de dire qu'est
ce qui va se passer en mars mais la
vraie logique du marché c'est qu'est ce
qui va se passer aujourd'hui en gros on
est effectivement dans le dé trading la
réalité au quotidien c'est ça a cessé d
être fun et céder
80% du volume qui passent au travers de
la spéculation sur les au tf alors mais
le tf recouvre tous les actions les
obligations les monnaies on en crée en
permanence de nouveaux des plus
originaux bientôt un le tf je crois sur
le lien entre le real
le rennais asamoah gyan et le dollar on
peut donc spéculer sur tout mais c'est
pour moi c'est presque plus grave que ça
c'est à dire qu'on peut le faire après
on va dire oui mais c'est vrai qu'un à
qu'ils font à la journée bien là qu'ils
font à six mois donc c'est vrai que tout
le monde ne spécule pas la journée sur
les marchés mais ce qui a dans la
logique des marchés c'est qu'on a
toujours l'impression qu'on peut
retourner la position c'est à dire que
je prends une position peut-être à six
mois mais au fond c'est pas très grave
parce que si on cours de journée voire
demain je m'aperçois que c'était autre
chose je vais pouvoir retourner la
position et ça pour moi il ya vraiment
deux catégories de raisonnement il ya
ceux qui pensent que rien n'est trop
grave parce qu'on peut retourner la
position et il ya ceux qui savent la
logique industrielle car à un moment
donné si on a commencé ainsi on danse on
chante comme ça si on voulait faire les
sillons dans l'autre sens un sacré
boulot pour reprendre est ce qu'on sait
pas ce sacré boulot qui fait peur à nos
gouvernants aucune goutte d'eau
gouvernants et cette peur on les met
dans une catatonique intellectuelle qui
ait le pouvoir de l'année la non
décision après moi le déluge
et on verra bien déjà ils sont
terrorisés intellectuelle ans parce
qu'aujourd'hui je voulais vous prenez
des intellectuels normaux ou des hommes
politiques normaux ils vont avoir un
avis sur la fonte frontière en macédoine
ou des trucs comme ça vous leur demandez
la finance ils ont là ça justement parlé
j'y connais rien à dire toi ma copine
ans a réussi oui mais lui va kroes il
est il fait partie justement d'experts
c'est quand même un banquier au children
shield donc à un moment donné c'est pas
de lui que viendra la réorganisation de
la finance stath lui faire injure que de
dire ça mais c'est
pour moi en gros la finance a réussi à
dire que seuls les financiers peuvent
parler de la finance
c'est comme si on disait que seuls les
spécialistes du nucléaire peuvent parler
l'énergie nucléaire où seuls les
spécialistes chimiste peuvent parler on
parlait tout à l'heure des des problèmes
de pollution vers l'est des pesticides à
un moment donné dans une démocratie il
faut accepter que certains médiateurs ça
s'appelle des politiques ça s'appelle
des journalistes s'appelle des ong
peuvent sans avoir fait trente ans de
marché avoir un avis pour dire ce type
de mécanisme était revers ce type de
produits est ce que tu viens de me citer
les journalistes voilà pu la presse
économique l'a beaucoup du mal à
survivre entre nous aujourd'hui on prend
la presse économique qu'est ce qui la
fait vivre c'est quand même largement
les banques si on regarde le nombre de
pages de pub dans un journal
que je ne citerai pas mais voilà donc on
laisse les puits sont pas vraiment les
moyens d'avoir un avis autonome sur la
finance n'ont donc les géniales les ong
à l'horizon angie ya find switch off
annonce ou qu'est-ce qu'ils font fait
non ils ont des moyens limités mais il
arrive quand même à pouvoir dire non on
peut avoir des avis un peu différent sur
la finance les points de charge à
regarder leur site donc on va regarder
finance watch philippe qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors failli dans ce match il
essaye un petit peu d'attirer
l'attention est ce qu'il faut qu'on
commence à aiguiser nos fours
je suis un petit peu rassuré
qu'effectivement on est des associations
des think tanks qui ont quand la
compétence de comprendre un petit peu ce
qui se passe les think tanks comprendre
ce qui se passe sous la main mise à part
les econoclastes au dessus
de chapeau aussi aux landais
pour faire un pitch très court
actuellement le système financier c'est
externe entre temps c'est à dire que
l'on roule la dette ont l'art finances
et on prétend qu'elle sera remboursé ce
qui n'est évidemment pas le cas parce
que parce qu'on a atteint largement est
très largement dépassé les limites
physiques des possibilités de créer de
la richesse hauteur des dettes qu'ils
sont
créée en ce qui concerne la dangerosité
du système et qui a été très très bien
illustré ces on peut tout on pense
pouvoir toujours retourner sa position
mais en fait il encore plus pervers
secunia beaucoup plus pervers c'est que
à un moment on se dit mince on commence
à se retrouver dans un contexte
d'illiquidité de nombreux actifs ce sont
les actifs obligataires le plus souvent
ils liquident même certains emprunts
d'états demeurent deviennent illiquides
la bce qui dit je peux augmenter de
façon infinie ou quasiment
usage de tous les instruments c'est à
dire mais des taux plus négatif ou
augmenter la taille des quantitative
easing en fait il devient difficile de
trouver des dettes éligibles pour être
rachetée par la banque centrale tout
simplement parce que par exemple
l'allemagne ont maintenant peu de dettes
et on est maintenant à pratiquement 30%
des émissions obligataires dont le taux
est négatif celle là la bce ne peut pas
les racheter est obligé de puiser dans
un gisement qui se rétrécit alors on est
à chercher du rendement sur le high
yield ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure
à propos par exemple des dettes des
groupes pétroliers ou des junior
pétrolière aux états unis donc on est
allé chercher du risque et aujourd'hui
on se dit ce risque malheureusement j'ai
peut-être pas pouvoir le retournement
m'en débarrasser ou leur tournée alors
qu'est ce que l'on voit refleurir les
seuls points les cds les assurances
contre le défaut de dette dont on sait
qu'elle va
mal on va donner les cds à jérôme parce
que jérôme les cds et son royaume jérôme
non mais je partage qui a été quand je
disais tout à l'heure le problème c'est
de croire qu'on peut retourner c'est
qu'en effet dans un marché dans
l'économie dans la vie dans 99% des cas
on peut retourner et puis 1% des cas où
on peut pas retourner et donc ce qu'on a
fabriqué ces des mondes où en gros tout
le monde gagne très bien sa vie 99 jours
sur 100 mais au prix d'avoir de faire
grandir sans cesse le coût potentiel du
100ème jour le jour où tout se ferment
parce qu'en effet quand ça se ferment
tous ces scénarios vous parliez tout à
l'heure des scénarios de crise sont des
scénarios qui sont bête comme chou c'est
à dire qu'on dit vous avez un bilan
imaginons que les taux augmentent de 1%
qu'est-ce qui se passe ah oui vous y
arrivez vous y arrivez pas très bien
sauf que le vrai problème c'est pas
celui là le vrai problème c'est de dire
brusquement plus personne madame la
banque ne vous fait crédit qu'est-ce qui
se passe et à ce moment là on peut avoir
tout le capital qu'on veut on meurt très
très très vite comme l'effet de levier
d'une banque aujourd'hui ces deux genres
un capital pour 30 da 86 90 et 2 3% non
quand même quand la bundesbank son effet
de levier non mais là les banques
centrales a pas retrouvées mais elles
émettent la monnaie donc alors c'est
elles qui font la liquidité donc elles
n'ont pas de problème mais une vente
banque vulgaire elles vont se retrouver
un pour 30 mais ça veut dire que ça veut
dire qu'elles tiennent très peu de temps
si tout s'arrête donc en gros tous ces
systèmes soi-disant prudentielles ne
tiennent que si l'économie tient si à un
moment donné les gens arrêtent de se
faire crédit tout s'arrête bâle iii
balles quatre vidéos pour des faits
quand on voit surgir des nouveaux
instruments ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné il ya des gens qui s'inquiètent
seneffe et qu'on cherche des couillons
pour reprendre certains risques plus ou
moins bien pas compte des primes plus ou
moins alléchante voilà et ça peut
continuer encore pendant un certain
temps mais tôt ou tard ces scellés les
courbes comme on dit les poteaux cursive
qui ont en gros qui n'ont pas la
gentillesse des bonne courbe de gauss
dans lesquelles les catastrophes
n'existe pas ce courbe sur lesquels sont
basés tous les modèles bancaires mais
qui sont des coquilles 10 de temps en
temps il ya des catastrophes eh ben
c'est qu'un jour la catastrophe arrive
et à ce moment là on découvre que tout
ce qu'on s'est créées comme effet de
levier partout vous expose à la foule
quand la mer se retire on veut qu est ce
qu un maillot de bain qui encore à
l'heure actuelle vous avez impayés dont
conseiller au cas où qu'il y a
jean départir d'europe
c'est qu'elle sera tous touchés partir
du moment où il ya des millions de gens
intelligents qui cherchent tous la
sortie c'est comme le bazar de la
charité
alors je sais qu'à un moment donné le
jour où ça se ferme ça se ferme surtout
tous voila il reste banner la charité
restait une fenêtre de 60 cm sur 60 cm
pour sa chapelle incendies y en a pas
beaucoup qui sont sortis donc à un
moment donné pour ne pas dire plus de
retraite ça veut dire plus de
financement de l'entreprise en général
et les états qui arrive et puis qui
essayent de plus mais ça c'était la
troupe maintenance et les banques
centrales est là on y est déjà on peut
toujours leur faire qu'est ce qu'il nous
reste comme cartouche juste une plus
grosse cartouche qu'on a fait comme en
2010 alors c'est avec façon l'esprit
humain c'est de refaire ce qu'on a déjà
fermé la grosse cartouche savoir quelles
répercussions sur monkey loudes pop
maman vont croissants le matin ses
comptes à un moment donné il pourra y
avoir en effet des prélèvements sur les
comptes rien un prélèvement obligatoire
oui je crois qu'il ya de plus en plus de
gens qui s'y habitue moi je rencontrais
des gens là qui disait qu on vient on va
nous prendre alors moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup inquiété c'est que je me suis
intéressé
à la garantie des dépôts bancaires
puis avec une petite addition une petite
soustraction de petites divisions je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait que 70
mille comptes qui pouvait être assurée
ce 5000 euros par contre oui non mais ça
fait que 70 milles compte en tout compte
tenu des réserves du fonds du fonds le
fonds le fonds fait 2 milliards c'est ça
de mire 5,2 milliards 5 donc 2009 5 ça
fait combien de comptes en banque
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup
donc qu'est ce qui se passe sur
l'indemnisation mille sont admises à 100
milles à
sur 250 me contre ces deux cent
cinquante mille comptes mais oui et ça a
toujours été ça toujours été vrai donc
le fonds garanti 10 baume au coeur c'est
du vent mais ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné l'activité bancaire n'est pas
capitaliser à hauteur de ces risques et
que donc il ya un droit de la
collectivité à dire il ya eu des tas de
débats au moment de la loi bancaire les
gens disant non ça n'est pas l'argent
des salles de marché qui sert aux
comptes épargne mais à la fin dès lors
qu'on a une seule institution c'est la
même institution qui signe tous ses
papiers et donc c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas d'argent dans cette réserve qui est
une réserve professionnelle qui est
maintenant est devenu un système
européen il ya bien sûr pas assez
d'argent pour une crise on peut se payer
une toute petite banque je donnerai pas
de noms mais patricia 12,1 en france non
non encore quelques petits bancs y en a
de moins en moins là la banque de france
je leur fais la peau mais il reste
encore quelques petites banques qui
pourraient être absorbés par ce système
mais une des grandes banques bien sûr ce
ne peut pas être protégé par ce système
est donc s'il ya une banque qui saute et
laissait forcément la collectivité qui
vient et donc nous et c'est pour ça que
nous on a notre mot à dire
le raisonnement de base il n'est pas de
dire on veut embêter les banquiers il
est de dire vous êtes en train de jouer
avec notre crédit de contribuables
peut-être le visa n'est que lui qui vous
permet de fonctionner vous ne pouvez
faire des opérations aussi gigantesque
que parce que derrière vous avez l'ombre
de la collectivité nationale qui vous
protège et donc rendez au moins un
hommage à cette ombre en l'écoutant ce
qu'elle a à vous dire philippe
londres on ne la consulte pas
elle n'a aucun pouvoir de contrôle
d'ailleurs quand dans les années
80 90 on a commencé à concevoir la
banque centrale européenne les
concepteurs
ont d'abord opté pour le principe de
l'indépendance et une indépendance qui
va donc très très loin puisque personne
ne contrôle ni n'évalue la pertinence la
dangerosité ou au contraire
peut-être qu'on pourrait le renvoyer des
tombereaux de lettres de félicitations
pour avoir inondé le système financier
de liquidités sortie de de l'air ambiant
on peut dire voilà
donc ces tombereaux de l'aide de
remerciement ce sont les financiers qui
lie pour l'assemblée des adresses et les
doutes ou les va dire allez les
questionnements
de plus en plus anxieux
du contribuable et du citoyen
tout rien ne remonte jusqu'à la bce est
de toute façon si jamais sa remontée ça
n'aurait pas le pouvoir
de lui faire expliquer quel est son plan
passant pas de prise voilà alors en
quatre histoires c'est déjà ce qui va se
passer c'est on a un exemple ces
chiffres on l'a vu et en italie aussi il
ya eu deux faillites ou deux ou trois
petites filles de deux banques de banque
dans le sud de l'italie au portugal où
effectivement ils ont pris sur les
comptes alors pas que pas qu' il y avait
des déposants dont on a dit écoutez vous
pouvez pas faire mieux ou trouver un
meilleur rendement que d'investir dans
les dents les dettes dans les créances
émises par votre banque elle est solide
on est avec vous et des gens investis
bonne partie de leur retraite une bonne
partie de leur épargne dans des emprunts
qui rapporte effectivement plus que que
les btp italien ou ou que va dire le le
coeur du rendement moyen des
des empreintes supervisé par la bce donc
ces gens là sont absolument tout perdu
puisque là on a et on arras et les
créanciers malheureusement ça n'a pas
suffi et il a fallu qu'on aille va
prélever les autres créances parce qu'en
fait quand on dépose de l'argent dans
une banque
particuliers ou personne morale on a une
créance sur la banque c'est tout votre
argent ne vous appartient plus alors
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce qu'on fait
et donc lorsque la banque à éponger tous
les créanciers
seniors qu'elles pouvaient après ça l
éponge le reste est dans les créances
dans lequel la banque peut puiser il ya
les dépôts les dépôts votre argent notre
argent donc mon argent ça m'intéresse
alors où est ce que je peux mettre mon
argent pour éviter ce genre de phénomène
disons qu'il ya d un trou dans un trou
dans le mur ou dans le sol des dépôts et
consignations la caisse des dépôts genre
oui mais comment on l'a mais il faut
agir pratiquement pas de comptes à
manquants mais ma connaissance peut-être
pour ses propres salariés mais
t'inquiète pas oui en gros si on a
passionné pas trop riche on peut on peut
espérer être protégés par la garantie à
70000 euros puis elle son conjoint il a
aussi 70000 euros on utilise plusieurs
banques et donc on peut se dire que
certes le fond ne suffira pas mais le
contribuable viendra à la rescousse et
après ce sera à l'impôt qui épongera et
pas forcément son épargne à soi
raisonnement un peu cynique il ya des
banques qui
n'ont comme seul rôle que de gérer et
dépôts qui n'ont pas de
qui n'ont pas la casquette banque
d'affaires qui ne pilote pas des
dragsters financier à des accélérations
de 0 à 4 100 km/heure en trois secondes
6 c'est-à-dire glass steagall act
banques et des vents il ya des banques
qui qui qui elles ne sont pas du tout
le glass steagall act ou dodd-frank se
nomme aujourd'hui ce que c'est d'être
franck n'entre pas en ligne de compte
puisque elles ne font pas du tout
d'activités de marchés elle gère
simplement les dépôts celle là me
paraissent relativement sûr des noms
à dire qu'il ya très peu d'offres en
france maintenant qu'ils ont des ventes
de 2,2 de dépôt pur il y en a encore en
suisse la banque postale on n'a pas
beaucoup d'activités de marchés
honnêtement crédit mutuel a beaucoup
d'activités de marchés du crédit mutuel
et ils sont pas de mèche avec le cic
s'il ya peu d'activités de marchés ils
en ont mais ils ont peu ou pas des
grands de l'activité de marché quand
même mallet le porte-monnaie nickel est
alors évalué dépôt on va changer de
sujet évasion fiscale la banque pasche
le documentaire sur canal + qui s'est
fait censurer
qu'est ce qui se passe avec l'évasion
fiscale jerou ckoi l'évasion fiscale l
évasion fiscale il ya la fraude et puis
à l'optimisation fiscale
traditionnellement on distingue les deux
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on
progresse un peu quand même
ce que l'utilisation c'est pas la fraude
qui dit pas son nom
bah oui mais enfin dans un état de droit
on est obligé de bien distinguer les
deux c'est à dire dans un cas la
responsabilité plus d'une responsabilité
de police et de sanction des malfaisants
dans l'autre cas c'est le législateur
qui doit à un moment donné
faire son ménage et faire que ce soit
pas aussi facile de tirer contre le camp
du des états puisque c'est encore ça la
réalité est aujourd'hui donc on est on a
quelques progrès et il faut bien dire
que c'est les etats-unis qui ont aidé à
mettre un peu d'ordre en disant demain
les états au lieu de se tirer la bourre
vont échanger des informations entre eux
alors je sais que tu aimes pas beaucoup
la notion d' échange d'informations mais
à un moment donné s'il ya des règles
collectives ont détruit une collectivité
s'il n'ya pas le sentiment collectif que
tout le monde applique la règle est donc
je pense qu'il est absolument impérieux
d'arriver à une solidarité minimale
entre les états pour se passer
l'information je suis d'accord avec toi
avec les états unis ont beaucoup
contribué mais j'ai l'impression que ça
marche que dans un sens c'est à dire que
les américains il aime bien que les
suisses collaborent il aime bien que le
luxembourg quatorzième bien que la
france collabore mais quand on demande
aux états unis collaborer dans l'autre
source oui les états unis sont pas un
endroit où il est tellement agréable
d'aller mettre son argent enfin je
connais peu de français qui cachent leur
argent aux états unis mais pour courant
des puits les usages mais les valides à
where de l' omc pour les sociétés c'est
par les assureurs les laboratoires
notamment philippe l'évasion fiscale les
chambres de compensation et tout ce
bordel là qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
dessus il fallait y quand on a conçu
l'euro disait d'eux de nous ramener
encore 25 ans en arrière mais enfin on
pouvait pas imaginer créer une monnaie
soit disant optimale dont dans un
ensemble où vous avez l'irlande qui
siphonne les recettes fiscales de ses
partenaires avec le luxembourg qui
propose d agrément ou vous convenait de
façon presque forfaitaire du montant de
l'impôt vous avez versé alors ça ça
existe en afrique je les ai vus en côte
d'ivoire notamment quand je dis vite
j'ai vu je l'aï vu de mes yeux vu
donc on peut venir
négocier sur la base d'une estimation
d'un bénéfice d'un rescrit fiscal vous
avez le système du double sandwich
irlandais je vais pas vous embêter avec
le circuit de
l'anéantissement de la facture fiscale
enfin
avec un triangle irlande luxembourg
hollande pour les holdings vous arriver
facilement à à baisser votre taux
d'impôt qui est je pense autour de 25 à
28 % en europe la france est
malheureusement un petit peu au dessus
enfin grosso modo
25 et 28 % celle un petit peu la norme
européenne en jouant bien sûr ce
triangle magique que vous à baisser
votre taux d'imposition environ 4% alors
comme tout le monde le fait pas
seulement les multinationales
américaines et les plus célèbres les
fameux gafsa qui ont tous eu recours
bien sûr à l'irlande et vous voyez qu'en
ce moment aux etats-unis la grande mode
c'est de racheter une boîte en irlande
pour ensuite délocalisé son siège social
et donc sa base fiscale en irlande où
c'est beaucoup plus avantageux qu'aux
états unis donc en europe tout le monde
s'y est mis il ya pas de raison que l'on
se passe concurrencée par des gens qui
ne payent pas d'impôts qui de ce fait
sont plus rentables ont plus de moyens
financiers plus ou moins
d'investissements plus de moyens de 2,2
jouer sur les tarifs et faire du dumping
donc tout le monde se met à faire de
l'optimisation fiscale en ne faisant que
des choses absolument légale qui mises
bout-à-bout arrive exactement aux mêmes
effets que si quelqu'un
frauduleusement dissimulé son argent au
fisc réclame tout tout est légal mais au
final le résultat est le même qu une
fraude aurait préféré répressibles non
oui mais à la fin bon moi je suis
internationaliste et donc je pense que
le problème il est il est bête comme
chou il est qu à partir du moment où on
a des acteurs qui peuvent jouer sur
plusieurs pays et que les puissances
publiques restent enfermés dans un cadre
national elles sont obligées d'être à la
fois limitée un peu bête c'est à dire
limiter ces je peux rien faire de ce qui
dépasse mon territoire et un peu bête
j'ai malheureusement est très court
terme intérêt si je m'appelle luxembourg
et que j'ai pas beaucoup de richesses
naturelles a attiré par des j'entendais
ce matin la radio qu on se félicitait
pas ce qu'il ya de plus en plus
deux films étrangers qui se tourne en
france la france a décidé il ya quelques
mois de faire un cadeau fiscal qui
jusqu'ici est à 20% à 30% à tous ceux
qui tournent leur casser un crédit
d'impôt donc c'est un chèque de 30 % des
dépenses qu'on leur fait bon et à se
gargariser les journalistes on est
vraiment les meilleurs les allemands
sont et les italiens c'est couillon sont
encore restés à 20% tout le monde se
congratulaient c'est à ça que j'appelle
est remettre ces cas en gros tout le
monde se dit ça c'est ça c'est finaux
non c'est pas finot parce qu'on ya
quelque part en allemagne quelqu'un qui
dira c'est quand même scandaleux ces
fragrances etc il vend des sens et qui
vont monter à 30 bon comme c'est le
cinéma bon c'est l'exception culturelle
tout le monde s'en fiche sauf que le
système marche en effet pour l'ensemble
des activités il fallait mettre
absolument un terme un phénomène c'est
que toutes les scènes des films
américains devant ce dernier qui c'est
censé se dérouler à paris était filmé à
prague parce que ça coûtait beaucoup
moins cher d'avoir des techniciens à
prague des figurants etc donc on va peut
être réussir effectivement à 6000
nouveaux apparus les sauver voilà non
non on a résolu auprès de nos problèmes
on va changer un peu de sujet ou
peut-être pas
je vais vous demander votre perception
autant comme sur des sujets voir à
forest ce soit rapide ce qui nous reste
plus beaucoup de temps jérôme état
d'urgence ça me fait penser à quoi
s'agit-il pas légitime fonctionne l'état
d'urgence c'est un piège à cons comme on
dit c'est comme beaucoup de mesure c'est
à dire que c'est des mesures dans
laquelle on rentre on sait pas comment
sortir donc là c'est ce qu'on est en
train c'est ce à quoi on est en train
d'assister
et donc je pense que l'état d'urgence a
été décrété pour une raison symbolique
là où on imaginait des situations de
guerre et de crise beaucoup plus faciles
à identifier et que donc c'était une
mauvaise solution donc on va traîner
pendant un certain temps
philippe état d'urgence
patriotes patriot act à la française
alors effectivement bas comme d'habitude
quand il ya une énorme émotion on prend
des mesures émotionnel et on arrive
aussi à faire d'énormes bêtises
politique je n'ai pas grand chose qui
distingue aujourd'hui le patriot act
américain des mesures qui ont été prises
en cascade depuis le 13 novembre bon là
la presse reste un petit peu plus libre
aux états unis on peut incarcéré un
journaliste si on considère que
il a mis en danger la sûreté de l'état
aux etats unis
la promesse de barack obama de lever le
patriot act cette promesse n'a pas été
tenue guantanamo non plus voilà jérôme
déchéance de nationalité
là encore un symbole qui est
complètement qui a complètement dérapé
c'est à dire je pense qu'en effet je
n'arrive pas à comprendre par quel
aveuglement
on a pris une mesure symbolique qui dit
l'exacte inverse de ce qu il faudrait
dire c'est à dire qu'à un moment où on
voit qu'il ya en effet
un risque qu'une partie de la communauté
nationale se sentent
ostracisé et puis ce pour les plus
fragiles écouter des sirènes tout à fait
noé abonde on prend une mesure qui avait
peut-être au départ une logique mais qui
arrive exactement à renforcer ce
sentiment d'ostracisation pour moi
c'était une mesure catastrophique crypte
moi je suis un petit peu plus
balancée sur le sujet parce que on a
bien compris que ça visait tout de même
les binationaux et
des gens qui sur notre sol
professe
de rejeter absolument la totalité de nos
valeurs laïques et républicaines
j'insiste bien sur laïque et
républicaine c'est une passion que s'est
affichée comme ça mais
ça règle absolument pas le problème
des gens ayant le même profil
qui vomissent le l'europe et ses valeurs
humanistes voulais retrouver aussi bien
en suède
car hambourg dans la banlieue de
bruxelles
voilà bon ça ne résout pas le problème
c'est vrai qu'à un moment bon c'est une
réponse symbolique mais je pense pas
qu'elle n'a pas n'a pas d'efficacité ça
veut simplement dire qu'on commence à
prendre conscience quand même quelque
part qu'il ya des gens qui
hot obtenu une nationalité française et
si on avait été plus à l'histoire
n'était pas preuve de plus de
discernement on ne leur aurais peut-être
pas offert jérôme
moi j'ai vraiment du mal à voir les
éléments positifs parce que je crois et
des lignes est positif c'est très simple
moi je voudrais vous avez pu nationalité
je vous emmène dans une prison secrète
dans le fin fond du cul de la pologne je
vais aller vous faire du waterboarding
pendant trois semaines je n'aime pas les
l'administration pour ça qu'on n'a pas
les moyens pour ça donc on s'est dit
c'est du fantasme c'est pas ça qui va se
passer sous traité c'est à dire que je
vais voir blackwater j'ai dit bon écoute
mon pote tu vas aller me choper ces gars
là tu vas me dire à venir le fait qu'ils
se soient plus de nationalité française
facilitera le waterboarding
ouais ou jeu pour lui mais pour moi il
ya une idée une idée de dire c'est
génial on va trouver un truc pas gênant
qui va faire plaisir à la droite sans
embêter la gauche et puis et puis ça a
dérapé mais là où je crois qu'il ya un
risque c'est que finalement on n'arrête
pas de parler des binationaux un sujet
dont on parlait pas beaucoup après on
peut dire c'est très bien qu'on parle
des binationaux moi je dis non c'est pas
ces pervers d'arriver à mettre le
projecteur de manière quand même
globalement négatives sur les
binationaux parce que après on tombe sur
l'ailé l'air tant que statisticien la
probabilité oui il ya peut-être un peu
plus de probabilités d'avoir des
terroristes chez un binational que chez
un français comme il ya un peu plus de
chance de ne pas rembourser les prêts
chez quelqu'un qui a eu un cancer que
chez quelqu'un qui a pas eu de cancer
la collectivité nationale est en train
d' interdire qu'on interdise de près les
cancéreux en disant qu'elle est
cancéreux guéri en disant c'est très
dangereux d'ostraciser une catégorie
même si statistiquement monsieur
l'assureur vous pourriez avoir un peu
raison quelque part ça n'a rien à voir
mais je dis c'est un peu la même chose
parce que on a observé qu'il y avait pas
mal de binationaux dans les terroristes
d'al est aujourd'hui ouvrir un débat de
dire les beats héros de bitter les bi
nationaux pourront être avoir une
punition que les autres ne risque pas
alors on change quand sujet la big data
la big data dans les marchés financiers
la big data dans les assurances
mais big data pour moi c'est un
gigantesque rideau de fumée une manière
de vendre de la puissance informatique
je vois j'ai travaillé dans des
entreprises je travaille dans des
entreprises je vois comment la plupart
des décideurs avec trois chiffres
n'arrive pas à prendre une décision ne
maîtrisent pas bien la règle de trois et
ils sont incapables en fait d'analysé
des données simples le problème c'est
que le cerveau humain des décideurs
n'est pas meilleure aujourd'hui qu'il ya
vingt ans mais les ordinateurs sont
quatre mille fois plus puissant comment
est-ce que diable on part faire vendre a
continué c'est quand même un miracle
avec ce truc qui double tous les mois
les ans et demi comment est ce qu'on
arrive encore à fait avoir des budgets
informatiques augmentent dans les boîtes
le big data est un des des uns des
arguments pour dire aux gens mais vous
saviez pas la couleur des cravates des
gens qui viennent dans vos agences
maintenant vous le saurez vous pourrez
prendre des décisions averti grâce à ça
et mon assureur qui a accès ou peu de
big data de ma cigarette connectés
et de la boîte noire de ma voiture
ce qui va augmenter mes tarifs ou les
faire baisser parce que je fume ou je
respecte le code de la route et ça c'est
une question vraiment collective en tant
qu'assureur on a eu tous les débats sur
les conducteurs est ce qu'on a le droit
de faire des tarifs différents pour les
hommes et pour les femmes maintenant
c'est interdit si j'ai bien compris donc
en gros le fait de savoir quelque chose
sur le risque n'applique pas qu'on ait
le droit de le transmettre dans un dans
un tarif et je pense qu'on aura un grand
débat dans les années qui viennent sur
cette notion d'algorithmes ans on voit
monter l'idée l'algorithme est ce que je
sais comment marche la boîte noire ou
pas dans l'ancien monde l'assureur
disait voilà le tarif des hommes voilà
le tarif des femmes demain est ce qu'on
aura des tarifs à la tête de pipe est-ce
qu'on acceptera les tarifs à la tête de
pipe en disant si c'est moins choquant à
ce tarif là et toi tu en as un autre et
à ce moment là est ce qu'on demandera à
voir dans les entrailles comment est ce
que ça fonctionne
philippe
d'un point de vue technique déjà
il ya tellement de data aujourd'hui
qu'il faut mettre au point effectivement
les outils pour les exploiter
soyons optimistes peut-être que certains
se doteront tels google pourquoi pas
amazon qui est dans le cloud est
aujourd'hui qui multiplie ses capacités
à faire l'informatique peut-être qu'ils
auront les moyens de faire quelque chose
de tout ça mais en amont avec une chose
qui me manque c'est le contrôle des
datas justement tout le monde
collecte des datas puisqu'on est on est
hyper connectés et
aujourd'hui où arrive toute les data qui
me concerne j'ai payé par carte bleue on
sait à quelle heure où on sait qu'elles
qu'elles billets d'avion j'ai pris
s'il est acheté un bouquet de fleurs
pour tu as folk et si j'ai voyagé en
catégorie à faire ou si au contraire
j'essaie de trouver un billet pas cher
avec un départ à 4 heures du matin
on sait en arrivant si j'ai pris un
petit déjeuner parce qu'il ne servait
pas dans l'avion enfin on sait
absolument tout
qui contrôle ça et
partant de là vu juste qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui à connaître au travers de
tout autre as
numérique ça veut dire qu'en fait
big brother il sait exactement où
quasiment ce qui s'est dit chez mon
médecin parce que quand je suis ressorti
qu'on a avec mon ordonnance je suis
allée acheter des médicaments haddock ou
j'ai fait un séjour à l'hôpital où j'ai
fait tel type d'examen j'ai tout réglé
par carte bleue
on ne prend plus mon liquide ton
téléphone sur la table et que j'ai
discuté avec mon avocat alors pour des
raisons au soin fiscal soit patrimonial
ou avec mon autre terre j'ai pris des
décisions les voit tout de suite parce
que j'ai versé des honoraires on voit
ensuite à la banque c'est eu des
mouvements de capitaux donc on peut
comprendre ce que j'ai fait est-ce que
j'ai que contrôle le contrôle je me
dirai ce que j'ai modifié mon môme
régime matrimonial est ce que j'ai fait
parce que j'étais malade
alors ensuite malheureusement
après ce que m'a dit mon médecin je suis
allé voir mon psy parce que ça c'est un
petit peu dur à encaisser donc on sait
que j'aille voir ainsi donc alors c'est
que mon cavron devient est
engagée alors que tu vas voir aussi
c'est ça la question qui contrôle les
donner quand on voit que l'europe et
c'est enfin de verrouiller les données
qui sont collectés par
à rebours et on compte plus de filles
transports lui transférer deux côtés de
l'atlantique alors peut-être
qu'effectivement on essaie de
verrouiller mais moi je suis sûr qu on
un jour on va on va glisser une un câble
une fibre et on arrivera à contourner et
à exfiltrer toutes les données vers des
centres de traitement aux états unis ou
pourquoi pas en chine ou ailleurs donc
vous voyez aujourd'hui la big data c'est
d'abord qui peut légitimement
l'exploiter et est-ce qu'il ya un moyen
que cette big veut que ce que ce que les
datas restent privés comme les
l'entretien que le médecin avec l'avocat
avec le notaire avec le psy dernière
question deux dernières questions jérôme
d'eduardo donne ça me fait penser à quoi
va rien de très original moi je
j'approuve la
possibilité de dévoiler
d
des secrets je pense que je parlais tout
à l'heure des institutions trop grosse
je pense qu'un des problèmes collectifs
que nous avons dans un monde de bulles
milliard d'habitants c'est
d'avoir des contre-pouvoirs
aux organisations très grosse donc je
salue les contre-pouvoirs pour rencontre
l'asile en france
je trouverais à ces crânes de lui donner
asile en france je suis paraît que ça
nous mettrait dans des relations
abominable avec les les états unis mais
on parlait de symbole tout à l'heure ce
symbole là envoie un autre je suis ami
des états unis je pense qu'on ressemble
plus aux états unis qu'à la russie où un
certain nombre d'autres pays la russie a
changé oui dans tous les sens soit
donc voilà c'est vrai que ce serait que
ce serait quelque chose de paradoxal de
sera conseillé avec la russie de se
brouiller avec les états unis je crois
quand même encore à la démocratie
américaine plus que la démocratie russe
mais au-delà de ça au delà de la des
plaisirs qu'auraient les états unis je
trouve qu'en effet ce serait crâne
philippe
on peut craindre ce que si on
accueillait snowdon sur notre sur notre
sol on verrait se multiplier les amendes
de type bnp ça te coûte très cher
maintenant je fais aussi partie des gens
qui sont
amis du peuple américain je suis pas je
ne suis par contre par certains
d'approuver toujours des mesures qui ont
des connotations un peu néo
conservatrice et j'observe que quelle
que soit la halle ternes ans politique
aux etats unis c'est plutôt la ligne néo
conservatrice qui perdure
et qui gérait même a tendance à
peser de plus en plus non seulement sur
l'échiquier géopolitique également sur
l'échiquier économique parce que a
essayé de dirt déclencher une guerre
froide avec la russie ça me paraît quand
même assez singulier le geste que je
sache le bon
c'est certainement pas joli la guerre
c'est pas beau ce qui se passe dans
l'aide de l'est de l'ukraine s'est
certainement pas terrible ce qui s'est
passé au maidan et certainement pas joli
non plus une analyse ça en détail et
qu'on voit le rôle des uns et des autres
et d'olivia wilde
mais jusqu'à présent on n'a pas encore
vu de terroristes
extrémistes ukrainien russophone venir
se faire exploser dans une salle de
concert et
et beaucoup de pays qui aujourd'hui
soutiennent un petit peu quand même
les mouvements terroristes et cela pour
l'instant sont totalement
vous dire indemne de toute mesure de
rétorsion
mise en coin par là vous parlez des
directeurs de catry que du côté de
l'arabie saoudite non non pas que
vainqueur l'année dernière question
jérôme un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
c'est une bouteille à la mer c'est à
dire que peut-être dans 50 ans on
retrouvera cette vidéo avec le conseil
que tu vas laisser aux jeunes
générations
pour en durcir leur esprit critique je
leur conseille quoi
alors de lire 1984 par exemple philippe
le ray ferme des animaux du même auteur
donc la ferme des animaux 1984 messieurs
merci
[Musique]
e
parent
[Musique]
non
le
[Musique]